Good morning, Scott.
Hey, good morning, Aaron.
Am I audible?
Yes, can you hear me?
Lovely, lovely. I can, I can. How are you, Scott? It's been a while.
I'm good. Yeah, it's been a while. Yeah, I've been busy. Sorry about missing some calls there.
Okay.
No worries, busy is good, busy is good.
Yeah, yeah, it keeps me out of trouble.
Nice, nice. So how are things on your end?
Going great. I'm going great. Yeah, Pearl's wonderful. We always love her, so.
Mhm.
Nice.
Nice. We love her too. Yeah, I'm glad she's living up to the expectations. And the numbers stay the same. I have the numbers for her for the month of May. And I mean, I can showcase them to you whenever you're ready.
Yeah, I bet.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Cool.
I will share my screen. Apologies for the camera. Actually, I'm working from home today. I'm not feeling well. So I just logged in for this call. I didn't want this one to get cancelled. So as this call is done, I will get off work.
No, no worries.
Yeah, but...
Ready? I will be sharing my screen now.
Please let me know once it's visible to you.
There you go.
I can see it now.
Ready, I'll jump right into it. Discovers the data between May 1st and May 31st.
The agenda would be check-in highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of the customer, and recap.
We'll start with the check-in first. What do you have any feedback for Pearl for the month of May? You, of course, work very closely with her. Any issues you've noticed, any feedback you've received from the team regarding her work?
No, no, she's great. Like I said, the only thing I did, I, you know, I changed her shift to accommodate our new hire and I kind of missed talking to her. You know, now we work almost completely opposite shifts. So I do miss talking to her. We do teams, you know, because I'm up late anyway, so I do check in with her and make sure.
Yeah, yeah.
Ahh.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Mm.
She should make sure she doesn't need anything or having any issues. So we did get to talk, but not as much as we used to.
OK, I understand, I understand, but, but still, I mean, anything's, I mean, she's...
Yeah.
Yeah, everything's no, everything's great.
Cool, cool. So the new hire, the person that you're talking about is working in the offshore hours as well. I mean, is Bill going to be in this shift permanently or you think she'll be once she does with the KT and she can get back to the prime hours?
Um, I don't know, Mike, the new guy's working 9 to 6 Eastern, 9 A.m. 6 P.m.
Mhm.
Kour.
OK.
We'll see. I mean, she's on a shift for now. We want to be a 24-hour shop, so we'll eventually have to hire somebody else.
Mhm.
Ah, mm-hmm.
Mm.
Um...
So, I mean, I think Chris Davis, my manager's manager now, he mentioned maybe getting somebody from you guys, but I mean, not anytime soon, but he did mention that would probably be the easiest. So I'm sure we'll be reaching out if that becomes, you know.
Mhm, mhm.
9.
Mhm.
Mm.
A thing.
Of course, of course.
But yeah, for right now, she's on this shift.
Mhm.
Till we get somebody else and have to.
I mean, I may adjust it just because there's gaps, we have gaps now. And from 6 P.m. to 9 P.m. there's a three-hour window that I'm kind of covering now, but you know, I don't know. I don't know. We'll figure it out. But no, she's on the shift for...
Mhm.
Mmh.
Right. Okay.
Mhm.
For the time being.
Okay, got it.
She seems to like it. She said she liked it because she works, she works days now. Yeah, so I don't want to disrupt that, but...
Of course, yeah, she gets to spend time with her family. Yeah.
Mhm.
Okay, okay.
So...
Sure, but you, I'm pretty sure you know that she'll accommodate if you want her to change her shift. She'll very happily do that for you.
Yeah, it won't be a huge change. It may shift an hour or two one way or the other. That's all. Nothing, nothing major.
Yeah.
OK.
Right, perfect. And like you said, I mean, of course, it's not anytime soon, but whenever you decide or think of adding another person here, of course, we'll try and find another pearl for you, for sure.
Okay, yeah, definitely. I would love Pearl's input on that too, because I'm sure she knows the text there.
Mhm.
Mm.
Yeah, absolutely.
Awesome.
Right, we jump on to the highlights. So this is what we are looking forward to in the upcoming slides. Strongest made throughput to 98 tickets handled across 20 working days with the 100% closure rate consistent with April delivery. Service delivery remains stable and reliable, but continues to meet expectations across ticket work and administrative responsibilities with no concern.
You.
raised by the partner. Stand out effort on the May 27th, 50 tickets resolved in a single day, demonstrating sure. Yep, surge capacity when the queue demanded it. May 17th, surge delivery, 36 tickets resolved in a single shift day alongside 0 non-billable hours, reflecting strong focus when in flow peaks. Hours mixed reflects dedicated services scope, admin, infrastructure monitoring, and operational tasks continue alongside ticket work.
Oh well.
consistent with the engagement model. Customer sentiment remains positive, Perl's ticket handling approach continues to be recognized with no escalations from the partner during the period. Capability development continues alongside delivery, Azure security upscaling remains on track and is being applied to live ticket handling.
If we jump on to, we can skip this part, and ITBD recommended KPIs have already been discussed as well. But if we jump on to the utilization for the first week of May, May 1st to May 7th, our billable hours were 42.7, non-billable were 57.3. Second week, that is May 8th to May 14th, billable hours dipped to 23 in non-billable hours. The other admin tasks hiked up to 77%.
Third week, billable hours, 53%, non-billable 47, and we can see a spike in the last week, 69% billable hours and 31% non-billable hours due to the high ticket volume. So the utilization moved from 23% to 69% across May, as you can see. But yeah, overall average, yeah.
Yeah, that sounds about right. I mean, it's going to fluctuate for sure.
Yeah, yep. And yeah, it's like I said, it spiked up to 69% because of the 80 tickets that she worked on in the last week and 46.3% was the total or rather average billable hours for her for the month of May with 298 tickets that she handled. Right. Jumping into the 298 tickets that I'm talking about in the first week, she worked on 69 tickets.
Right.
Okay.
second week, 38 tickets. Again, the expectation is to close or rather work on 40 more than 40 tickets in a week. So 69, then 38, and then back to it. Yep, she is. And then 80 tickets, 82 tickets rather in the third week and 109 in the last week that she worked on. So yeah, that's the kind of performance she had this.
I was just doing that.
Ha.
this month so far in the month of May, I think I remember it was around 250-ish in the month of April. So yes, she did exceed the previous performance. But yeah, I was pretty happy when I was making this data. So but want to hear from you as well. What do you think?
Yeah, this will be good evidence that we'd need a third person.
Yeah, awesome. Right. So yeah, the utilization and the closure part is done. Apart from this, I don't think we have anything else. We just rest of the slides is just information on the AI by design, which you're already aware of. But not sure if you're aware of the build it. Are you going to build it this year, Scott? Or have you ever been to?
Now, I never get to go to those things. No, I haven't.
Oh, mhm.
Santeep always mentioned it, but yeah, I don't get to go to these things. They keep me in the closet working.
Mhm.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
So anybody else from Iron 24-7? Anybody anything that should or might be interested in visiting this? New Jersey, New Jersey.
Where is it this year? New Jersey, okay. Yeah, I'll mention it to my boss, but you know, he usually gets to get out of the office, go to these things. I know he just went to Dad.com in Vegas not too long ago.
Mhm.
OK.
Okay, cool. So you're talking about Kris or?
Chris, usually, yeah. I got a new boss, Eddie. I was going to ask if he wanted to be on this call, but maybe next call, I'll see if he wants to join.
Okay.
Andy.
Sure, if you want again, just let me know his email address. I'll share the invite with him.
Okay, yeah, I'll confirm with him, see what his time looks like.
Right.
Okay.
Alrighty, so yeah, I'll just let my CX team know if they want to send an invite to, not an invite, but an email inviting him, inviting them rather to the build it, Eddie and Kris. And I mean, it's going to be great this year. John C. Maxwell is going to be there along with very, very, very good speakers.
Oh, nice.
Kam.
Oh.
which is very difficult here, but yeah. So I mean, yeah, let's hope it works out. Otherwise, yeah, my boss would be there definitely. So hopefully they get to meet. So let's see how that works.
Okay.
Okay, yeah, yeah, definitely send one, at least send it to me, I can forward it to.
Right.
Perfect.
To whoever, if they're interested.
Alrighty, we'll do. We'll make sure somebody sends that out to you today, Seth.
I appreciate it.
Right, that would be it. I will stop the share. And I was also thinking of, I'm not sure if ever, I mean, I just recently got a connect, I mean, recently got engaged with you on this account. It was somebody else handling this account first. It was Sarbjeet, if I remember right. Have they ever talked about the other services that we have? I mean, you were saying that.
Okay.
I mean, of course, in future you might think of adding another engineer, but there are other services regarding NOC services which could provide you block hours support where you said there's no, right, taking the current scenario, just as an example, like between 6 to 9, there's nobody available, you said. So.
Mm.
you could get services from the shared NOC that we have here for a few hours only that could cover those shifts. So that could do the trick for you as well. And instead of investing for a whole new, I mean, one engineer as a whole, you can also get services for block hours, like four or five or six hours you can decide. And then my shared NOC.
team over here who work on multiple accounts, they can provide you with the support on your servers and firewalls and workstations, everything. So just give it a thought. It's something that we do usually in case you think that might do the trick, that might help you out, just let me know.
Okay, sure thing.
Cool. All right, anything else for me, Scott, before we wrap up?
No, that should be it.
Alrighty, thank you Scott. Thanks for joining in. And anything pops up, if anything pops up, just let me know. I'll be offline, but still, I'll be checking my emails for sure.
All right, thank you. I feel better.
Pre.
Alright, sure. Thanks. Alright, alright, bye.
Right. Thank you, Scott. Thanks for joining. Bye. Bye.